We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here's the Baltimore City County line. Weapons in the arsenal of exclusion, alphabetical.
我们的赞助商包括加州大学戴维斯分校，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问21stCentry.ucdavis.edu了解更多信息。这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是巴尔的摩市县分界线。排他武器库中的武器，按字母顺序排列。
Arm rest on benches, blood relative organs, blockbusting, bouncer, cotosac. I think cities are great. There's movement and activity and diversity, but go to any city and it's pretty clear a place can be diverse without really being integrated. Cities exist to bring people together, but cities can also keep people apart. That's Daniel Diocca.
长椅扶手、血缘器官、地产恐慌、保镖、cotosac。我认为城市很伟大。那里有运动、活动和多样性，但去任何城市都很明显，一个地方可以具有多样性，却并不真正融为一体。城市的存在是为了让人聚在一起，但城市也能让人分离开来。那是丹尼尔·迪奥卡。
My name is Daniel Diocca, and I am an urban planner. I have a company in New York called Interboro Partners. Over the last few years, Daniel and his two colleagues at Interboro Partners. Interboro Partners is myself, Georgian, Theodore, and Tobias Armbors. And the three of us, working on this project for a number of years called the Arsenal of Exclusion and Inclusion. This arsenal is a catalog of stuff inside a city.
我叫丹尼尔·迪奥卡，是一名城市规划师。我在纽约有一家名为Interboro Partners的公司。在过去的几年里，丹尼尔和他在Interboro Partners的两位同事。Interboro Partners就是我自己、格鲁吉安、西奥多和托比亚斯·阿姆博斯。我们三个人多年来一直致力于这个名为“排他与包容武器库”的项目。这个武器库是对城市内部各种事物的分类目录。
What we call weapons. Concierge, Expulsive Zoning, Fire Hydrant, Food Truck Ordnance. That architects, planners, policy makers, developers, etc. use to either bring people together or keep people apart or open the city or close the city or increase access to space or restrict people's access to space and a number of ways to spin it. Historic preservation, home-motors association. Weapons ranging from no loitering signs to big things like housing vouchers and exclusionary zoning and all that kind of stuff. Today we're only going to focus on the arsenal of exclusion, the weapons that keep people apart. Weapons in the arsenal of exclusion.
我们称之为武器。礼宾部、驱逐性分区、消防栓、餐车条例。建筑师、规划师、决策者、开发商等利用这些来让人聚在一起，或者让人分离开来，或者开放城市、关闭城市，或者增加对空间的访问权限、限制人们对空间的访问权限，以及多种变通方式。历史保护、家园汽车协会。从禁止逗留标志到诸如住房券和排他性分区等重大事物的各种武器，诸如此类。今天我们只关注排他武器库，即让人们保持分离的武器。排他武器库中的武器。
In the city of Baltimore, a place Daniel Dioca truly loves. I taught at Maryland Institute College of Art for six years. So I have a strong connection with Baltimore. It's still a city that I love and admire very much. It's a wonderful place. But it's a city that has been honing its arsenal of exclusion for decades. Baltimore was once to the invisible wall building industry, what Detroit was to the automotive industry,
在巴尔的摩市，一个丹尼尔·迪奥卡真正热爱的地方。我在马里兰艺术学院教了六年书。所以我与巴尔的摩有着深厚的联系。它仍然是我非常热爱和钦佩的城市。这是一个美妙的地方。但它是一个几十年来一直在打磨其排他武器库的城市。巴尔的摩曾经是无形墙建筑行业的底特律之于汽车行业，
an innovative workshop where creative minds work to think up and vent, test out and ultimately export methods of exclusion. Our producer and resident, Baltimorean Sam Greenspan, went to look at some of Charm City's exclusive offerings. So, before we're the best way to get there is... Oh, sorry. So, what, you tell us, tell us, why don't you say what? Where we're gonna go and what we're doing and what we're gonna go.
一个创新工场，富有创造力的头脑在这里思考、发明、测试并最终输出排他方法。我们的制作人兼常驻巴尔的摩人格林斯潘去参观了查姆城的一些独家产品。所以，在我们去那里的最好方式是……哦，抱歉。那么，什么，你告诉我们，告诉我们，你为什么不说说呢？我们要去哪里，我们在做什么，我们要去哪里。
How are we gonna get there? Give me a second. Sure. Dan Dioka and I are driving north of Greenmount Avenue in East Baltimore. I kind of think of Greenmount North of 33rd, all the way up to Cold Spring as a kind of museum of exclusion. So as you're driving north on Greenmount Avenue, north of 33rd Street, it's clear that Greenmount Avenue is a dividing line between rich and poor and black and white, but what's not immediately obvious is why. Just to give you a sense, as we drive north on Greenmount to our right, on the east side is waverly.
我们怎么去那里？给我一秒钟。当然。丹·迪奥卡和我正驱车前往东巴尔的摩格林芒特大道以北。我有点把33街以北一直到科尔丁的格林芒特视为一种排他博物馆。因此，当您向北驱车沿格林芒特大道行驶时，越过33街向北，很明显，格林芒特大道是富裕与贫穷、黑人与白人之间的分界线，但并非显而易见的是原因。为了给您一个概念，当我们沿着格林芒特向北行驶到右侧时，东侧是韦弗利。
Waverly is lower income and around 80% African-American. 16% of a bachelor's degree, a median income is $40,000. And on the other side, on the west side to our left is Okenshron, then Gilford, well to the north of that, a really affluent area buffered by a middle income area, only about 7% African-American. 75% have a bachelor's degree and the median income is $75,000. In Daniel Diocos' view, it's not the wide green mount avenue that keeps these neighborhoods apart. It's actually the small and subtle and invisible, yet totally intentional things that keep these
韦弗利收入较低，大约80%是美国非裔。16%拥有学士学位，中位收入为40,000美元。而在另一侧，即左侧的西侧是奥肯什伦，然后是吉尔福德，再往北一点，是一个由中等收入地区缓冲的非常富裕的地区，非裔美国人仅占约7%。75%拥有学士学位，中位收入为75,000美元。在丹尼尔·迪奥卡看来，并不是宽阔的格林芒特大道让这些社区隔离开来。实际上是那些微小、微妙、隐形却又完全刻意的事物让这些
neighborhoods separate. Demographically, the divide is very strict and severe. You can just see all these physical measures that are deployed to keep people from getting from one side to the other. Just crossing green mount on foot is annoying. Two crosswalks in that 1.25 mile stretch. But what's more interesting is when we talk about the grid. Gremount is where the grid ends.
社区保持分离。从人口统计学来看，这种鸿沟非常严格和严重。你可以看到所有这些物理措施，它们被部署用来阻止人们从一边走到另一边。仅仅步行穿过格林芒特就很烦人。在那个1.25英里的路段上只有两个斑马线。但更有趣的是当我们谈论网格时。格林芒特就是网格终结的地方。
The grid is there and wavily on the east side. Notice that on the right, there's the grid, right? There's 37th Street, 38th Street. We can make a right into wavily, no problem. But on our left, there's no grid, right? It stops. You'll notice we're heading north now. If we try to make a right into Waverly, no problem. But on our left there's no grid, right? It stops. You'll notice we're heading north now. If we try to make a left, we're gonna be confronted with dead-end streets, ballards. Where's the ballard? It's there like these security poles that you kind of stick in the ground. Oh, here's a wall, right? There's this long row of
网格就在那里，在东侧的韦弗利。注意右边，有网格，对吧？有37街，38街。我们可以右转进入韦弗利，没问题。但在我们的左侧，没有网格，对吧？它停了。你会注意到我们现在正向北行驶。如果我们试图右转进入韦弗利，没问题。但在我们的左侧没有网格，对吧？它停了。你会注意到我们现在正向北行驶。如果我们试图左转，我们会遇到死胡同、路障。路障在哪里？它就像这些你插在地里的安全柱。哦，这里有一堵墙，对吧？有长长的一排
middle-income houses on the west side of the street. They're kind of a buffer against the really wealthy gilford stuff that's just behind. Almost all of the roads dead houses on the west side of the street. They're kind of a buffer against the really wealthy Gilford stuff that's just behind. Almost all of the roads dead end at the houses, and the few streets that do go through are mostly one-way streets coming the opposite direction out onto Greenmount. There's no way for us to get left into Okentrav or Gilford. There has to be some way to get into the neighborhood.
位于街道西侧的中等收入房屋。它们有点像对后面真正富裕的吉尔福德事物的缓冲。几乎所有的道路都在房屋处成为死胡同，而少数穿过去的街道大多是单行道，从相反方向通往格林芒特。我们没有办法左转进入奥肯特拉夫或吉尔福德。总得有某种方法进入这个社区。
Well, there is, but on Gilford's east east side you really have to go out of your way to find a street that will let you in. So now we're in gilford finally. And then once you're inside you'll notice two things. The houses are super nice and the roads are super weird. The roads are windy and they feel disproportionately small next to these houses giant lawns and you need a permit to park here. Another interesting one is residential parking permits.
嗯，有的，但在吉尔福德的东侧，你真的得绕远路才能找到一条让你进去的街道。所以现在我们终于在吉尔福德了。一旦你进去了，你会注意到两件事。这里的房子超级漂亮，这里的道路超级奇怪。道路弯弯曲曲的，在这些房子的巨型草坪衬托下，它们显得不成比例地小，而且你在这里停车需要许可证。另一个有趣的是住宅停车许可证。
Residential parking permit. In case you're wondering, you do not need a permit to park in the less affluent, wavrally neighborhood. But back to Gelford. The weirdest thing about these roads is that it's hard to know what direction you're going. And could you tell if we're east, north, west or south, right? It's really hard to tell, right? I would imagine we're going. And could you tell if we're East North, West or South North? It's really hard to tell, right? I would imagine we're going South.
住宅停车许可证。如果你想知道的话，在收入较低的韦弗利社区停车是不需要许可证的。但回到吉尔福德。这些道路最奇怪的地方在于，很难知道你开的是什么方向。你能说出我们是向东、向北、向西还是向南吗？这真的很难说，对吧？我想我们正在走。你能说出我们是向东、向北、向西还是向北吗？这真的很难说，对吧？我想我们正向南走。
I think we're actually going East. So this is Greenmount Avenue. Since we're outsiders and we don't know our way around Gilford, we were shunted out of the neighborhood on a one-way street back out onto Greenmount Avenue. So this is one of the one-way streets heading out of the neighborhood. Oh my gosh. So we really
我想我们实际上是在向东走。这就是格林芒特大道。既然我们是外地人，对吉尔福德的路况不熟，我们就通过一条单行道被挤出了社区，重新回到了格林芒特大道。所以这是驶出社区的单行道之一。哦天哪。所以我们真的
got out back to Remount and I thought we were going through it. These physical barriers and the arsenal of exclusion, grids and one-way streets are not that big a deal. They're not that hard to overcome, but their placement has meaning. This really matter that you can't make a left turn into Gilford would this be a more equitable city if we could make that left turn? Probably not, right? I mean, it's more of a symbolic thing, right? It's this place where this demographic divide is just rendered very physically in space.
回到了格林芒特，我以为我们要穿过去。这些物理屏障和排他武器库、网格和单行道并不是什么大不了的事。它们并不难克服，但它们的位置具有意义。你不能左转进入吉尔福德真的很重要吗？如果我们能左转，这里会是一个更公平的城市吗？可能不会吧？我的意思是，这更像是一种象征性的事情，对吧？这是一个人口鸿沟在空间中变得非常物质化的化身。
But it's worth noting that other weapons in the arsenal of exclusion that once existed here in Gilford are now illegal, like restrictive housing covenants. Basically, there were housing ordinances that said black people can't live here. Restrictive housing covenants. Diocuses that this neighborhood actually pioneered the use of segregationist covenants, housing deeds that restricted occupancy to only white people. This
但值得注意的是，这里曾经存在的吉尔福德排他武器库中的其他武器现在是非法的，比如限制性住房契约。基本上，当时有住房条例规定黑人不能住在这里。限制性住房契约。迪奥卡说，这个社区实际上率先使用了种族隔离契约，即限制房屋仅由白人占有的房契。这
wasn't illegal until 1968. You can point at these gridless streets as being an emblem of the racial segregation that still exists in Baltimore. With good cause. When it's interesting to speculate what the neighborhood would be like, if these exclusionary measures weren't in place. Had this neighborhood been built on a grid, upper-middle-class white people living here, probably would have fled to the suburbs in the 70s, 80s, right? Given that there are rich white people still living here within the city limits paying city taxes, is it worse than just having all the rich white people living out in the county? Yeah, I mean, it's a really good question.
直到1968年才成为非法。你可以指责这些没有网格的街道是巴尔的摩仍然存在的种族隔离的象征。事出有因。当人们去推测，如果没有这些排他性措施，这个社区会是什么样时，这很有趣。如果这个社区是按网格建造的，住在这里的中上阶层白人可能在70年代、80年代就会逃往郊区，对吧？鉴于城市范围内仍然有富裕的白人住在市内并缴纳城市税，这难道比让所有富裕白人都住在县里更糟糕吗？是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常好的问题。
And the trick is to try to develop neighborhood change, and that's not a zero-sum game, where one party loses and another party gains. And that is in a borough partners next project, creating development solutions that are not zero-sum games. But it all starts with labeling and categorizing the weapons and the arsenal of exclusion and inclusion, so we can figure out how to create cities that are more open to everybody. Here's a little in-note. Most of the weapons in the arsenal of exclusion create barriers that are hard to see because
诀窍在于尝试发展社区变革，这不是一个此消彼长的零和游戏，不会出现一方得益而另一方受损的情况。而这正是Interboro Partners的下一个项目，创造并非零和游戏的开发解决方案。但这一切都始于对排他与包容武器库中的武器进行贴标签和分类，这样我们才能弄清楚如何创造对所有人更加开放的城市。这里有一个小尾声。排他武器库中的大多数武器创造了很难看到的障碍，因为
they are subtle and non-descript, except when they're not. Here's the Baltimore City County Line. Dan Yoka took samples to the former side of Hollander Ridge. It was a lower-income housing project, but way out on the City County Line. It has since been torn down, but one artifact of the project remains. The Rosel community up there, Lobby, to build this eight-foot-tall spiked, rot-iron fence around the perimeter of Hollander Ridge, I'd a separated from their community, which then was predominantly white suburban community.
它们微妙且不具特色，除非它们不是这样。这里是巴尔的摩市县分界线。丹·迪奥卡去了霍兰德岭的前址取样。那是一个低收入住房项目，但位于市县交界处。此后它已被拆除，但该项目的一个遗迹依然存在。那里的罗泽尔社区游说在霍兰德岭的周边建造了这个八英尺高、带尖刺的熟铁栅栏，我将其与他们的社区隔离开来，当时那是一个主要是白人的郊区社区。
It's like a gated community created from the outside. You know, it's a really strange and unfortunate thing. It's funny that the spikes are actually pointing the other direction. So I guess you could go over but you couldn't get back. Right. 99% in visible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars with help from Scott Goldberg. We are a project of KALW 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. 99% Invisible is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more
这就像一个从外部创建的封闭式社区。你知道，这是一件非常奇怪和不幸的事情。有趣的是，尖刺其实是指向另一个方向的。所以我想你可以翻过去，但却回不来。对。本周的99%隐形节目由萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作，斯科特·戈德堡提供了帮助。我们是旧金山KALW 91.7地方公共广播电台以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。99%隐形由PRX分发，公共广播交流中心让公共广播更加
public at PRX.org. Support for 99% Invisible is provided in part by tiny letter. Email for people with something to say. My boy Carver always said something to say. What do you have to say, Carver? Every year, the volcano is formed, and we love every year. Shh, it's going to get a lot of fun.
公共，网址是PRX.org。99%隐形的资金支持部分由tiny letter提供。专为有话要说的人准备的电子邮件。我的男孩卡弗总是说有话说。卡弗，你有什么想说的？每年，火山都会形成，我们每年都喜欢它。嘘，这会变得非常有趣。
But it's not that close to us, so it doesn't kill us. It only kills the people who's definitely really close to it. Just tell the people who close it. Stay away, get out of your house. So they don't get killed by the car, walk in. Now that's a reason to send a newsletter. Maybe even a follow-up phone call. Tiny Letter, the simplest way to send an email newsletter.
但它离我们不太远，所以它不会杀死我们。它只杀死那些离它真的很近的人。只告诉那些靠近的人。呆在家里，滚出你的房子。这样他们就不会被卡弗杀死了，走进去。现在这就是发送电子通讯的理由。甚至可能是一个后续电话。Tiny Letter，发送电子邮件通讯最简单的方法。
Tinyletter.com. You can find the show and to send an email newsletter. tinyletter.com. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars. You can always catch up with us and look at more weapons in the arsenal of exclusion at 99%invisible.org. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Tinyletter.com。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并为其点赞，我在推特上的名字是Roman Mars。你随时可以在99%invisible.org上关注我们并查看排他武器库中的更多武器。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。